listen closely it's very important that
you pay attention to the visuals you're
seeing and the words you're hearing you
may think you've heard this story before
you get that funny feeling deja vu but
trust me this is all very much new to
you this is the story of a dangerous
species of anomalous creature dubbed
scp-939 also known as with many voices
on october 28 1981 it all started with
an scp foundation field agent going
missing while on duty the whole case had
smelled like death from the beginning on
the edge of an undisclosed city in an
undisclosed american state civilians had
been going missing in unusually high
numbers this would be a concerning state
of affairs in and of itself but things
went up a notch when law enforcement
operatives sent to investigate them
disappeared too disappearances are hard
enough to cover up law enforcement
disappearances are a nightmare if only
it stopped there when the foundation
agent went missing alarm bells were
ringing across the entire district what
the hell kind of threat could take out
civilians trained law enforcement
officers and even foundation operatives
naturally the next step in this
escalation of force was to dispatch a
heavily armed and well-prepared tactical
security force known as trapper from the
nearest foundation containment site
these were six of the best tactical
operators from the sector whatever it
was that killed or took out the others
it wouldn't do the same to them or at
least not all of them the team breached
an abandoned multi-level warehouse on
the edge of town based on the estimated
points of disappearances for the various
victims it was the most feasible
location of an anomalous threat they
used explosive charges to enter the
building and stormed in assault rifles
and submachine guns blazing the team
split up to search different parts of
the complex in a move that even the
mystery gang could tell you doesn't
often work out well though many
scooby-doo episodes might have played
out differently if shaggy was wielding a
heckler and coke
hk416 it didn't take long for the
overpowering stenches of death and decay
to assail the team's nostrils they'd
work for the scp foundation for long
enough to know the distinctive sickly
sweet aroma of rotting human flesh from
memory with heightened awareness they
continued through the building searching
for the source of that awful smell a
member of the team radioed in when they
made the first grisly discovery the
corpse of a missing foundation field
agent killed by what seemed to be one
huge bite taking a fatal chunk from his
neck some kind of animalistic beast had
taken his life in a single decisive
strike once again the danger level had
elevated for the trapper team but it was
about to get a whole lot worse for all
of them some of the team that had split
to check the upper floors of the
warehouse suddenly heard the most
terrible shrieking from the lower levels
they heard their teammates calling for
help clearly distressed they weren't
even using their radios they just kept
screaming and yelling begging the others
to come down there and help them but as
the rest of the team descended into the
lower levels they soon realized that
they've been lowered into a trap by
beasts far more intelligent and
diabolical than they'd ever imagined
this was the story of the first time scp
foundation operatives ran into specimens
of scp-939
and lived to tell the tale in the
darkness below that abandoned warehouse
building they discovered a teeming den
of monsters large quadrupedal beasts
with translucent red skin and long
vicious spines streaking their back
trails of human flesh dangled from their
long fangs the monsters were standing
atop the corpses of the team members
who'd been calling for help moments
before or rather
seemed like they were calling for help
moments before the scp-939 instances had
borrowed the voices of their prey to
order a slightly more substantial dinner
from above one of the two most potent
abilities of scp-939 is their power to
mimic voices and do so with genuinely
terrifying accuracy it is currently
unknown to the foundation how exactly
they do this because 939 specimens don't
actually need to hear a voice before
they can imitate it and the complex
structure of their imitations and speech
patterns suggests a far greater level of
intelligence than their more
superficially bestial nature implies
theoretically you could hold an entire
conversation with a 939 behind a screen
door and have no idea that your
conversation partner was a creature that
would be just as happy to chew the head
off your neck as they would be to talk
to you speaking of which back to the
trapper team the survivors were cornered
by a gaggle of monsters using the voices
of their dead teammates the creatures
advanced with dripping [ __ ] preparing to
lunge and add another few bodies to the
count thankfully the survivors thought
fast opening fire and escaping out into
the hall as the creatures pursued after
a tense firefight and calling in a hefty
contingent of reinforcements from a
nearby containment site the trapper team
just barely got the situation under
control narrowly avoiding becoming just
another voice in the repertoire of this
particular 939 nest the foundation were
able to capture several viable specimens
and bring them in for containment and
study while some lives were lost the
monsters were caught but 939 stands
apart from the rest of the anomalous
crowd in a number of ways including the
fact that its true horrors were only
unleashed after containment the trapper
team that had fought tooth and nail to
apprehend the creatures in the first
place began to behave strangely during
debriefing despite their communication
devices recording a relatively clear
audio account of the incident the
survivors experienced odd lapses in
memory details that likely would have
been burned into the mind of anyone else
experiencing these events were
completely absent from the recollections
of the team members it was a phenomenon
the foundation had only seen once before
it was the exact kind of behavior
exhibited by people who have undergone
amnestic treatment it was this
comparison that led them to discovering
scp-939 second potent anomalous effect
they quite literally breathe a form of
aerosolized amnesic dubbed
amnc227 it inhibits the part of the
brain that allows people to form
memories for the duration of their
exposure to the gas creating a kind of
memory camouflage that 939 specimens are
able to hide in the gas is odorless
colorless and tasteless you could be
standing in a room full of it and never
even know they only tell that you'd ever
have memories erased by amn amnc227
is a strange sense of deja vu you'll
experience if you return to the point of
exposure it was an amnestic compound so
effective the foundation floated the
idea of using it for their own purposes
seeing as it's a lot easier to get amn
c227 from 939 than the usual method of
sacrifices to anatashisha from perfect
voice mimicry to impeccable memory
erasing with the added bonus of
intelligent pack hunting and an
exceedingly powerful bite strength 939
appeared to be a species of perfect
predators for luring in and killing
humans naturally the foundation had
questions chief among them being what
the hell are these things and how do
they work the more the foundation
experimented on scp-939
the more they became keenly aware of the
fact that these things don't operate
like any other living being almost all
of their internal systems from veins to
their digestive system are entirely
vestigial beneath their translucent skin
these monsters are effectively dead
nothing works and somehow nothing needs
to work they consume human flesh but the
flesh simply rots in their stomach until
they later vomited out nothing about
their biology explains how they produce
amnesics or how they even technically
survive one sample was fully dissected
it's different vital systems placed into
various tubes and the monsters still
tries to talk to foundation personnel as
they walk past its containment location
some of the creatures childish ranting
was recorded for posterity and the
recordings are nothing short of truly
chilling have you seen our pictures we
like drawing daddy hung them on the wall
except for sometimes when the others in
white coats took them away daddy told us
not to draw pictures like those they
made him sad so we did our best to draw
other things but sometimes we forgot
sometimes daddy hid the pictures or
ripped them up he told us that it wasn't
that he didn't like them he said it was
to keep us safe from the mean doctors in
the white coats but then the doctors
took daddy away
and some of the things said by this
dissected creature have been even more
disturbing we got so hungry it was bad
but we ate our old skin and our old head
it tasted good but it was still bad we
were still hungry after that and asked
for food they gave us food even our
favorites but none of it tasted right to
us all that tasted good was one piece of
meat we asked for more of that in hopes
of understanding their biology better
the foundation also decided to run some
samples through scp-914 the clockworks
as expected the coarse and rough
settings destroyed and deconstructed the
creature the data on the one-to-one
setting was redacted but most
frightening of all was the results of
the fine and very fine experiments for
the fine setting the creature simply
came back dead for the very fine setting
the creature had been reduced to a
smoldering pile of white ash the only
conclusion we can take from this is that
on a truly cosmic level 939 is meant to
be dead and just when you think that
scp-939 has hit the ceiling on true
horror the monsters continued to impress
by raising that nightmarish bar after 11
years in containment one of the 939
specimens gave birth to a litter of
infants this doesn't seem all that
horrifying seeing as being able to
reproduce would at least give 939
something in common with the rest of the
animal kingdom but the foundation were
horrified to find that the larval stage
of scp-939 looks pretty much identical
to a human baby researchers who were
ordered to dissect these creatures
finding out in the process that they
were identical to human infants on the
inside too were offered amnestics due to
the understandably traumatic nature of
the experience one of the births was
stillborn and the others quickly
cannibalized it the surviving beasts
soon learned to perfectly imitate the
voices and behavior of human children
offering yet another reason that you
cannot trust any of your senses when it
comes to scp-939
as they grew and matured the more human
parts simply fell off like a snake
shedding its skin after a period of
prolonged pain and discomfort more so
than most creatures the foundation
contains
scp-939's very existence is enough to
cause a sense of existential dread and
for a creature as full of surprises as
scp-939 of course there would be another
twist in the long red tail you see we
mentioned earlier that the scp
foundation briefly considered using amn
c227 the amnesic gas exhaled by 939
specimens as a form of class b amnestics
however this plan was later cancelled
when a horrifying side effect came to
light amnesia is never a good feeling
having complete blank spots in your
memory is actually extremely distressing
to experience and as we mentioned
earlier people exposed to amn c227 seem
to experience a palpable sense of deja
vu when they first experience it it'll
be mild but it'll slowly get stronger as
they move towards the source little by
little you'll feel satisfaction drawing
closer until you're wandering into a
deep dark cave and before you know it a
set of red jaws are closing around your
neck and it's all over that's right
amnc227 not only wipes the memories of
encounters with scp-939
it also lures any survivors back into
the lair of the creatures they've been
given the ketter class because there's a
whole species of these things and even
the foundation's best scientists can't
know for sure how far their habitats
extend they could be waiting for you
right now ready to call to you in a
friendly voice so remember kids don't
believe everything you hear after all
sounds can be deceiving now go check out
evil monster created by scp foundation
scp-2419 the laughing men and scp-002
the living room and the most terrifying
scp rooms for more terrifying scp
creatures